- Go map who
you want to be like,
email them cold,
and their inner circle,
until one of them says,
sure, you can come work
for me for free as my
admin or my chief of staff,
and move to L.A. and do it.
- [Jewell] Makes sense.
- It will work.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- Here's why,
you can always go back
to what you're
doing now in 24 months.
The practical world
is always open armed.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It's what the
whole thing is built for.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- That's what people don't get.
The practical world?
The way school is built,
to be an employee?
They're waiting for you always.
They're always there for you.
- [Jewell] Mhmmm.
- To me, that's
how I see the world.
It's actually a
no risk game.
It doesn't go away.
- [Jewell] Yeah.
- It's always there.
(light music)